you say cyrus on se retrouve pour une
vidéo un peu spécial c'est le bac dans
quelques jours et du coup vous êtes
nombreux à m'avoir demandé une vidéo
spéciale pour le bac
vu qu'on a peu de temps on me dit que ce
serait pas mal de faire une vidéo sur
comment bien réviser le bac de philo
alors niveau timing si vous commencez
vos révisions maintenant c'est pas ouf
c'est pas obligé quand même en parler
pour les personnes qui verront cette
vidéo et qui passent pas le bac dans
quelques jours idéalement vous révisez
voilà au cours de l'année avec votre
cour un genre essayé de privilégier le
court a parfois des fiches hyper
synthétique que vous pouvez trouver
parce que ben c'est beaucoup plus facile
de comprendre avec un cours qui
développe et c est quand vous réalisez
votre cour essayer de dégager le plan du
court et de prendre voilà deux trois
idées principales par partie si vous
permettra de dégager une idée globale de
votre cour il ya vraiment deux grands
partis dans les révisions du bac de
philosophie il ya la forme et le fond
qu'il faut vraiment travailler genre
faut travailler les deux ans délaissé 1
le fond c'est le contenu vous devez
avoir une idée claire de chaque notion
notamment grâce aux définitions et ça
sert à rien d'apprendre une définition
que vous ne comprenez pas tu vois
vraiment faire cet effort de
compréhension de la définition et
ensuite vous l'apprendrez en plus vous
l'apprendrez plus facilement si vous la
comprenez hockey une fois que vous avez
appris vos différentes notions de
manière très claire grâce aux
définitions vous devez être capable de
faire des liens entre les différentes
notions c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
dans les coups de fils par exemple genre
parfois à la fin d'un coup de fil je dis
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on avait vu
avec des philosophes ou alors telmex
s'oppose à sa danse telle vidéo etc
essaie de faire c'est bien là ok ok t'as
compris d'ailleurs parfois vous allez
devoir faire le pont entre deux notions
par exemple sur un sujet comme est il
absurde de désirer l'impossible c'est un
truc que j'avais vu sur internet je
crois que c'était le sujet un sujet 2009
est bien là ce fait appel à la notion de
raison est il absurde et à la notion de
désir
donc là vous êtes obligés de faire le
pont entre ces deux notions là par
ailleurs je vous mets dans la
description de la vidéo une fiche hyper
synthétique qui a été fait par la page
50 nuance de l avec l'osr est et c'est
une fiche un peu collaborative où chacun
a mis par notion bas parce que tel
philosophe pense et c'est une manière
hyper synthétique vachement bien je vous
mets ma description il ya une prof qui
disait qu'il vaut mieux savoir peu et
bien que beaucoup aient mal et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ça
dans ce qui est contenu il ya un truc je
ne peux pas ne pas vous en parler vous
le taf et sûrement beaucoup c'est les
citations
ok alors les citations juste abusé pas
de ça dans votre copie j'attaque copie
ça doit pas être un catalogue de
citation parce qu'en gros si tu fais un
catalogue de citation ça donne
l'impression que toi tu connais pas
grand chose tu vois et que tu te reposes
trop sur des citations
donc c'est un bon dosage tu vois c'est
un peu comme la cuisine c'est un peu le
sel geste mais trop de sel tunique ta
copie là bas c'est un peu pareil enfin
si tu es trop de sel tunique ton plat
parce qu'en fait si tu mets du sel sur
ta copie à pala nikkei a aucun intérêt
sauf si tu mange ta copie par contre une
bonne situation bien utiliser au bon
moment au bon endroit avec pertinence
toi qui est vraiment en rapport avec
tout ce que tu viens de dire avant bout
c'est un peu le fatality dans mortal
kombat quoi
en plus ça montre que tu as une rigueur
parce que c'est à dire que voilà tu vas
tu es capable de utiliser la bonne
station au bon endroit
bon avec précision tu as monde rigueur
précision c'est un peu aussi ce qu'on
attend dans une copie toi au bac de
philo
pour tout ce qui est de la forme j'en ai
déjà parlé longuement une vidéo que
j'avais fait il ya deux ans je vous mets
le lien dans la description
donc c'était une vidéo sur la
dissertation et dedans il j'ai fait
aussi un renvoi vers une vidéo sur le
commentaire de texte
voilà tu as fait bien ça comment réviser
la forme c'est très simple mais en fait
quand tu prends tes annales l'idée c'est
pas de lire le corriger tout de suite
soit tu lis pas le sujet avec le
corriger dans la foulée non tu vas tu
lis le sujet tu essaies de te poser à
peu près un quart d'heure avec une
feuille et un stylo et genre juste
développer des idées voir jusqu'où tu
peux aller dans tes idées voir les
connexions tu veux faire entre elles et
essayer dégager un plan une
problématique et ses toits juste en gros
de l'entraînement de plans et de
l'entraînement problématique toi
autre chose d'à copie de philo lé
personnel tout ce que vous apprenez dans
votre cour ça nourrit votre réflexion
pour pour le devoir ok ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que la réflexion
seul ça suffit pas et le court seul sans
réflexion derrière ça suffit pas non
plus c'est vraiment les deux qu'il faut
mettre en avant ce qu'il faut donc c'est
que tu es des pensées claires donc avec
des définitions qui permettent d'avoir
une pensée personnelle qui va être
structuré avec un plan qui sera
argumenté est nourri par des exemples au
niveau des exemples vachement important
essayer vraiment vraiment d'éviter tout
ce qui est tout ce qui peut être
polémique en fait je vois genre tu sais
pas qui va lire ta copie ça se trouve le
mec qui va lire ta copie c'est un gros
raciste ça se trouve c'est chez pas ils
détestent la cgt j'en sais rien je n'en
sais rien mais évite au maximum tout ce
qui peut être polémique dans ta copine
genre si tu veux faire de la polémique
mais ouvre un blog tu va cartonner
mais évite de le garder pour ta copie de
philo
premier conseil que je veux dire c'est
allah d'avoir le bac de philo comme ce
gros monstre qui est difficile à
appréhender non ça va bien se passer
ça va bien se passer si tu t'appelles tu
prépares le truc et a aucune raison que
ça se passe mal ok c'est possible c'est
faisable
tu vas le faire tu vas faire tu vas le
faire moi ton programme de révision il
reste peu le jour et même ceux qui
regardent ces vidéos plus tard et qu'ils
auront plus de temps
planifiez vos révisions mais genre
vraiment précisément tu vas genre tant
de blocs d'heure sur ce truc là sur ce
truc là et c'est machin c'est ça qui
vous permettra de voir à quel point vous
êtes en retard ou en avance sur vos
révisions
généralement on est plutôt en retard
chose à vous et c'est ça qui vous
permettra de aussi prioriser ce que vous
aller réviser parce que vous pouvez pas
tout révisé n'oubliez pas aussi que
c'est une période où c'est pas une
période de révisions c'est que c'est pas
une période d'acquisition acté
normalement tu apprends plus grand chose
à ce moment là parce que trop de trucs à
apprendre c'est plus tu revois des trucs
que tu as plus ou moins appris dans
l'année ensuite fait des fiches utile
souvent les fiches elles sont blindées
genre et dans l'info plein de couleurs
dans tous les sens ok si ça marche pour
vous ok je sais que la plupart des gens
ça marche pas comme ça en fait faut que
les fichiers soient hyper synthétique
avec des mots clés tu vois que genre que
tu ailles droite au but quoi parce qu'on
sait que par exemple les épisodes du
coup de fil c'est que cinq minutes parce
que à la base l'idée c'est un peu ça
c'est de faire un truc qui y perd ce
soit ce genre soit ou de pointe droite
au but en français autre point juste la
veille faites pas le truc du mais qui se
couche à 3h du mat mecs ailleurs la
veille tu fais ton programme de révision
la philo c'est hyper important que on a
bien dit qu'il y avait une partie
contenu donc une partie savoir et c'est
qu'on apprenait avait une partie
vraiment réflexion ta réflexion sur le
moment et ça faut que je sois frais pour
ça et c'est la première épreuve situe là
commence mal situe la foire genre tu vas
pas être dans un superbe état
psychologique pour le reste des épreuves
donc d'ailleurs autres points si tu le
rates l'épreuve stoïciens stoïciens
s'est passé ça dépend plus de moi
concentre toi sur la suite d'accord mais
tout ça pour dire que et c'est d'avoir
une bonne nuit de sommeil et d'y aller
se rend au maximum voilà c'était
quelques tout petits conseils parce que
vous êtes beaucoup à me l'avoir demandée
j'espère que ça vous aidera j'espère que
vous donnera la motive et bon courage et
bon courage ça va bien se passer et
surtout une fois que vous avez passé le
bac de philo que vous avez passé le bac
n'arrêtait pas la philo c'est dommage de
voir ces disciplines seulement comme un
truc pour le bac pour avoir une note et
cetera c'est bien plus que ça donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à continuer de votre côté
avec des vidéos sur youtube par exemple
c'est pour ça qu'il faut s'abonner et
dernière chose
l'oeil du tigre ouais tu vois c'était
que la dans leur bureau qui avant notre
combat je me suis entraîné à fond mais
j'avais pas ce regard là toi tu l'avais
et tu as gagné
il faut que tu retrouves ce regard-là
l'oeil du tigre mec
oui il a eu du tigre